on a obtenu des avancées moi vous savez
j'étais plutôt au départ sur les 65 ans
mais d'abord j'ai voulu qu'on soit
cohérent avec le Sénat qui avait proposé
chaque année un amendement 64 j'ai voulu
j'ai mesuré aussi qu'il fallait pas que
cette réforme soit trop brutale d'un
coup pourquoi nanella parce que depuis
2017 je le redis mais c'est essentiel on
a rien fait donc on arrive monsieur
Macron arrive au pied du mur et la pente
pour sauter ce mur que subissent les
Français elle est plus raide donc moi
j'ai voulu atténuer cette brutalité
comment bien on est passé de 65 à 64 on
a pris en compte aussi c'était pour nous
essentiel le fait qu'on revalorise les
petites retraites parce qu'il y a des
Français qui ont des retraites indignes
ça a été fait 1200 euros brut c'est un
pas important on le doit aux
républicains nous avons fait une chose
aussi importante c'est de dire il y aura
pas de hold-up tel que le gouvernement
le prévoyait sur les fonds de réserve
des régimes complémentaires les régimes
ont complémentaires agir Carco ils sont
très bien gérés d'ailleurs c'est un
exemple pour l'État parce que ce sont
les partenaires sociaux qui gèrent le
Medef les syndicats qui gèrent ils
agissent il y a 70 milliards d'euros
d'excédents donc ça veut dire que ça
marche et l'État voulait faire un petit
prélèvement ou même gros là dessus on
l'a empêché on a une clause de revoyure
en 2010 en 2027 donc on a eu ces
avancées il reste des points sur les
femmes notamment sur la carrière des
mers plutôt que les femmes je les femmes
bien sûr mais les maires de famille